[Music]
long distant sailors who braved months
alone at sea tend to report that their
greatest challenge is the soul
destroying loneliness were prone to
feeling lonely when were socially
isolated but we can also feel lonely one
we're not isolated when we're in
relationships with people who care about
us so what is that terrible loneliness
as philosopher Bertrand Russell puts it
where one shivering consciousness looks
over the rim of the world into the cold
unfathomable lifeless abyss loneliness
is the unwelcome feeling that we lack
companions that we have fewer or poorer
relationships than we want
feeling lonely is like feeling pain
first and fear it triggers our
fight-or-flight response in small doses
loneliness can help us it can prod us to
reach out to other people but when
loneliness becomes chronic and acute its
corrosive some of us turn to drugs to
deal with loneliness some of us join
abusive relationships or gangs
it's correlated with health risks such
as depression reduced immunity and even
suicidal behavior studies indicate that
young people feel lonely as often as
older people do even young children can
feel deep loneliness if loneliness is a
serious social problem what do we do
about it can we have a right not to be
lonely we cannot have a right against
feeling lonely but we could have rights
against some of the underlying
conditions that tend to cause loneliness
such has a right not to be persistently
socially isolated including a right not
to be left to fend for ourselves when we
need help to stay social like the
physically impaired person who needs
some help to get out of the house
although this isn't currently an
explicit right in international
agreements arguably it should be because
human rights are about the Brutes
moral minimum that we each other as
human beings in addition to talking
about rights we can work individually to
alleviate our own and each other's
loneliness there is value in small
social connections like the visit to the
doctor the ride on the bus and the trip
to the grocery shop
we can make it a habit as writer George
mom bios adjusts to start conversations
with people we don't know these micro
moments of connection aren't just nice
according to social psychologist Barbara
Frederickson they change us for the
better emotionally and physically it's
like getting exercise and it goes both
ways our hearts capacity for love are
based a biological law use it or lose it
as children singer Charlotte diamond
puts it give four hugs a day that's the
minimum not the maximum thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
click the bail to receive notifications
for new videos see you again soon